[Music]
please don't get involved
what is up the keys thick of tears
three thicker rats
thickos
what is happening man it is monday
morning may 9th
and i look exhausted i look like a real
exhausted trash panda right now it's the
name of the new tour 2022 trash panda
tour after shooting especially can't do
your same material anymore so that the
the rebranding of the tours let you know
it's a whole new hour coming in freaking
thick
that's right shout out to charlotte had
a great time in charlotte it's the best
crowd that i've ever had man uh comedy
zone is a special place so shout out to
charlotte man stayed in the hood this
thing about uh not staying hotels doing
airbnbs we don't know the city we don't
my brother's my road manager and he
books it he doesn't know charlotte and
uh when they we landed from the airport
and they dropped us off the tax
taxi driver goes you guys are staying
here
man these houses are nice they put the
houses in the hood hoodies oh it's bad
around here man it really is i'd stay
indoors okay that's cool but um what can
you do that's what makes it fun it keeps
you on your toes fellas jen you're
looking awfully nice today new cardigan
that's some yeah i guess it's new i wore
it already really
since i've been here no probably not
you're good all right thanks bro was
that h m no it's uh asos oh no okay i
know damn he's rich yeah rightly rich
rich it's cheap no you deserve it man
thanks man uh you know i'm fresh off the
plane from uh new york so i had a hell
of a run promoting the the special the
gringo poppy
thank you guys so much everybody that
watched it
um the love that i'm getting on the
street at the shows it's insane man so
that's why i put on youtube and god dang
was that the right choice so i can't
thank you guys enough man i can't thank
you enough so my schedule was flew to
austin did rogue did shows with rogan
wednesday night
uh did rogan jre uh podcasts on spotify
which is available right now me and joe
rogan
and then uh flew back home for two days
and then sunday flew to
um new york and uh
new york was uh
new york is a special place man new york
is such a special place and um
it was such a a great trip for me man it
was such a great trip and you know i
don't get out to new york a lot i wish i
could get out there a lot more i have
some great friends out there
and um
you know it kicked off monday morning
with uh chris destefano who i absolutely
love and adore he has a podcast right
now here's a podcast um
on i'm sorry he has a special called
especially weshy especially weshy i
think yeah which is on uh netflix so
he's 36 minutes of it is on netflix and
the rest of it goes on youtube so he's
the best of both worlds oh that's nice
yeah he's crushing it and that thing's
trending everywhere and it's so good and
chris is one of my very favorite people
in the world and the the man behind all
of chris's stuff is a man named homeless
pimp
so homeless pimp is the gentleman who
he's the the comedy seller in new york
which is
um
basically like um
the the seller's new york's version of
the comedy store it's it's you know it's
it's lambeau field it's madison square
garden for comedy the biggest comics are
there he's the guy he is the guy he's
the in-house photographer he has shot
some of your
favorite specials
he's the brains behind a lot of uh
things that your your favorite new york
comics do
and uh he vlogged my entire trip and
you know there's just um
when you when you're doing this stuff
and you're going through promo and stuff
like that you know homeless pimp and i
have met a few times these have been
great to me but we really got to know
each other on the strip because he's
with me
24 7 monday tuesday wednesday
and so uh we just you know he's a
special special dude man he's such a
good person um so we went from uh shout
out to homeless pimp by the way so we
went from to stefano to schultzy's show
and obviously schultz and i are super
close uh he's crushing it from shochi's
show with akash and his entire staff i
went from there and then we went to um
i think that was that that might have
been it that then the next day was
barstool sports with uh kfc kevin oh i'm
sorry monday
monday i had uh
just this is my day i'm sick of hearing
myself talk uh on monday i had
de stefano who's a you know a tidal wave
of energy
flagrant two with akash and schulte who
are monsters
and then um
i had this show which i'm familiar with
just because you know they're popular in
the podcast space and i try to you know
see what's going on
but i don't know them and uh
they're two comics named kevin and foley
foley's the big guy and kevin is the
smaller guy and they do a podcast
called um are you garbage
and
i reached out to all my friends who were
big in new york in the county scene
every single person said do this podcast
these are two of the the best guys in in
the space do this podcast i've never met
them we exchanged texts like three weeks
prior because akash made the connection
he was like it may definitely do this
podcast man they're so much fun
and i was like yeah i don't know them
though you know i saw tim dillon on saw
mark norman um
schultzy was on there i was like yeah
all right you know i wasn't that excited
about it
and i get to their studio they they
accommodate them like okay
you were talking about schedule hey we
leave tuesday morning so um if you want
to do it we have to do it monday night
and i go that's the only time i can do
it
we're free man they make it happen
these two guys man are you know in the
comedy space i've been so fortunate
because i have so many great friends
they are the most genuine authentic and
hilarious guys you ever meet and their
show
yeah i was telling brian about this i
was calling brian you know brian's from
new york so i was talking about new york
and where to go
these two uh kevin and foley remind me
of a time and it's one of the best
moments of my life when me and brian
were coming up and we're just on the
cusp of of doing something big we're
just on the cusp and we're hustling and
we're excited and we love each other
which we still do but if there's just
like this
it's like you know in fighting when
there's the come up and you're watching
the come up and these guys are the next
they're gonna be huge they're gonna be
so big man and you can feel it and
everybody in the room knows it and they
have this special formula and you know
we do a podcast
it's kind of general same concept every
time you know
especially with comics you know and
everyone has their own flavor and it's
fun
but what these guys do is they dive into
your your childhood and your come up and
then at the end they say are you garbage
well we knew i was garbage two minutes
into it but their formula is so unique
and original you won't see anything like
it
it's
you know i've done i don't know how much
i've done my ten thousand ten thousand
hours of podcasting
this has to be one of the top hours i've
ever done
it's just so different than anything
you've you listen to
and it and they have such drive and
passion and excitement they're such good
guys and great comics and they're coming
up and it just remind me of of brian and
i coming up and
you know i got i got back in the car i
wanted to cry man i want to cry because
you know i've had a great life and
you know those guys are doing it and i'm
just so grateful for for them and the
support and they're just genuine
freaking human beings and they're funny
and they're grinding trying to make it
and you know they're not they're not
balling like everybody else that you see
but god are they on their way man it's
it's such a special thing it's hard to
describe men but shout out to those boys
they they just got some special man
they're just on the cups they're just
getting started
so then uh yeah the next day was bar
stool kfc those have been my guys
forever forever i've been uh repping bar
stool
and then uh it was garyvee and i was
excited for the garyvee one because
um
you know garyvee is a guy who uh again
i'm not familiar we don't know each
other and he texts me man yo what's up
man big fan love to have you unheard you
come to new york who's this garyvee the
garyvee yeah man got your number from
blah blah blah oh [ __ ] so we linked up
and uh
he's just i have a lot of time you know
he's he's he's like rob daredik
everything's scheduled so he had about
45 minutes for me we went in an hour
before his podcast but just a smart
smart dude and me and him are similar
where we tell everybody we we
when we leave even if i barely know you
i say love you
he says the same thing
so we're in the pockets like i love you
man love you bro we just met each other
yeah so he was a special dude and uh you
know i saw a broadway show by myself i
went to uh mr saturday mr saturday night
um with billy crystal he's 72 and it was
so good it was so freaking good
um but yeah new york is such a special
place i ate at the same restaurant every
night it's called taiga shout out to
tyga
it's uh
it's asian food i don't know what kind
of asian food i had like this uh cool
like uh lobster fried rice and then they
had these these noodles yeah that's it
right there tiger bites uh not tiger
bites uh tiger restaurant new york
it spelled like tiger the rapper
i think so
[Music]
uh it's not in tiger by it's a different
place it's in new york um
let me spell it differently see if that
works yes no that's not it
um
nope that's that's uh port washington
new york no it's it's in uh
it's right by where i was staying i was
staying at the nomo soho uh
just fantastic
bottom line food was fantastic your boy
went off his diet during the the press
tour oh that's it right there though see
that it's called the tiger go back there
right yep that's it man south yeah east
asian restaurant my god it's off one
howard so there's 11
howard 11 or 11 howard hotel it's right
across the street from there
and they have this pasta it comes with
fish skin on it oh yeah oh that's it
right there bro
every night i had that every night
i'm that guy where i find something i
like and everything house made egg
noodles the staff was fantastic
and they had steak so i could check that
box
then i'd go to prince pizza
your boy fat out there man back on the
diet now back on the frickin diet now
but uh yeah shout out to everybody in
new york man i had such a great time
such a freaking great time
i was in charlotte uh like i said this
weekend i'm in philadelphia next weekend
next thursday friday saturday
i'm in philadelphia one of my absolute
favorite cities
uh i have great friends out there at the
suplex uh shoe store
and you'll know suplex if you watch food
truck diaries um because they're the
ones that provide the shoes for all the
fighters so that's my boy um at suplex
and i'm excited to get to philadelphia i
haven't been there in a hot secular at
the helium there next thursday friday
saturday that's may 19th through the
21st philadelphia and i cannot wait man
i just
can't wait to get out there chin's
coming hell yeah little brows is coming
yeah big j shobb david the squad is
there
ah i'm looking forward to it man i'm
really looking forward to it so that's
next week thursday friday saturday and
that is the trash panda tour whole new
hour not an ounce of what you saw on the
special is in this new hour man so i'm
excited for it super excited for it
philadelphia i will see you soon and
then portland is june 9th through the
11th i'm in san francisco june 17th
through the 18th that's at cobbs
so yeah man uh it's good to be home it
felt weird being gone i i've you know
i'm a guy i don't i don't miss but this
was important with my special i had to
uh do this you guys would
who have been listening to me for all
these years no i i would not miss unless
it was really important that special was
really important to me man and i'm so
proud of it i'm so happy the feedback
i'm getting and the views and i just
can't thank you guys enough man so i
[ __ ] love you guys
for everything that you do and subscribe
and watch and
um
yeah i wouldn't miss unless it was
really important this this was important
for me
this is a feather in the cap for me you
know doing a special myself and doing on
thick boys so it's a big deal uh but
missing i had anxiety like crazy i had
anxiety like crazy i missed a fight
companion i missed a fight companion
uh but matt matrion held the fort down
he did awesome i heard he did phenomenal
and i knew he would you know i love matt
absolutely love matt and rashad i you
know me rashad uh spoke and it's just
such a shame i wasn't there because
obviously rashad's one who gave him my
start for those of you don't know he's
the reason i got him the ultimate
fighter
um it's because of rashad he had a lot
to do with it so i owe a
great debt to shot evans so he'll be
back i will definitely back when i'm
there i i would love to do the next
fight companion uh the ultimate fighter
10 reunion you have rampage rashad oh
yeah matt myself and we watched the next
big pay-per-view and
just have some fun man and rampage miss
i don't think he's i want to spread
rumors i don't think he's covered but he
wasn't feeling well so you know
let's take a little break from me
chatting about all the fights then we
get right back to the program listen
two out of three bros will experience
some form of hair loss by the time that
they're 35 more than 50 million dudes in
the u.s suffer from male pattern
baldness i see it when i'm on the road a
lot of y'all dudes losing your hair my
friends that keep they got you
covered keeps offers a simple affordable
stress-free way to keep your freaking
hair you conveniently meet with a
virtual doctor all right and then you
don't even need to leave your home you
just meet with them online dude we have
24 7 care and support it's low cost
start at just ten dollars per month
keeps offers generic versions all right
um keeps has everything you need to keep
your hair fantastic it's delivered
straight to your door discreet little
package shows up proven results remember
prevention is key don't look like george
costanza don't wait it's too late
treatment can take four to six months
see results so act right now it comes to
your hair save more spend less
all right if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com shop
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com shop
s-e-h-a-u-b to receive your first month
of treatment free
that's keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com shop to get your first
month free keeps.com shop gotta keep the
house lights on and pay the thick boy
employees so here's another commercial
for you it's the nba playoffs we're in
the second round baby it's getting hot
it is getting hot and draftkings is an
official sports betting partner the nba
new customers can bet just five dollars
on any team to win and get 150 dollars
in free bets instantly you clinch a win
no matter what all draftkin sportsbook
customers can also bet on nba hoops with
the same game parlays combine multiple
bets from the same game for a bigger
payout the more legs you add the more
money you can win baby plus for each day
of the play-in get a risk-free bet up to
ten dollars if your same game parlay
doesn't hit download the draftkings
sportsbook app right now use the promo
code shobb s-e-h-a-u-b bet five dollars
on any nba team to win their game during
the playing tournament and get 150
dollars in free bets instantly that's
promo code shobb s-e-h-a-u-b a draft
king sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nba minimum age
eligibility restrictions supply c notes
for details see next page for
directions for disclaimer
draftkings promo code shobb but let's
get in the fights that's why you guys
are here
um
[Music]
again i was in charlotte but i was able
to see the main
card
of ufc what was it ufc 2 74 74
in phoenix arizona
uh
you know the main card we're gonna talk
about the main card the main card um had
its moments
but for the most part you know
it was tough it was tough you had two
split uh decision three split decisions
the co-main event
you know we'll call it what it is this
i'm not throwing shade at either one of
those world-class fighters um sometimes
this happens
terrible fight it is what it is terrible
fight
but uh
fortunately for the ufc and the the the
fan base that paid money to watch this
fight card you had michael chandler tony
ferguson and you had charles oliveira
and justin gaichi
and a pay-per-view is really uh
remembered for its main event this main
event delivered
and i think any hardcore knew that
michael chandler tony ferguson was
actually really the main main
fight we wanted to see
and boy did it live up to the hype we
knew it was gonna be a barn burner but i
don't think anybody predicted a machida
style ko over tony ferguson um you know
i always like to give out mvps
charles oliveira is not gonna get the
mvp just because he missed weight if he
didn't miss weight he'd still be my mvp
over michael chandler but because
michael chandler you know came in the
ufc and was he two and two and but he's
never had a boring fight
and i think for chandler and ferguson
this was a kind of a crossroads whoever
won this fight was gonna go this
direction which you know you get all the
accolades in the world you go you lose
you go this direction gets dicey you
don't want to go to the right it's dark
and dicey and it's pretty sad
and unfortunate that happened for tony
ferguson i think this is four losses in
a row now if i'm not mistaken it's four
in a row
but i i you guys should be nice to tony
ferguson because
it's four let me go over his four losses
justin gaichey okay you're talking about
one of the very best in the world
charles oliveira okay talk about the
world champion uh darius okay talk about
the guy who could fight for a title if
he beats uh makachev and then michael
chandler
okay so he's lost to the very very very
very best
and you know he's out of his prime he
did win nine in a row and we never got
the khabib fight but tony ferguson is
still a top 10 lightweight in the world
despite
you know if you go on social media right
now i'm sure everybody has a picture of
tony first thing getting kicked in the
face and that's a shame but that's the
nature of the business
uh when a knockout like that happens
it's
you know it's on espn it's on social
media it's espn top ten everybody's
talking about it and you know it's
unfortunate for tony ferguson it's great
for michael chandler you know um
so for for michael chandler
he he gets this
top five knockouts of all time doing a
guy against tony version top five
knockouts of all time a front kick that
he does not train you know he just said
he you felt right and thought the middle
is open throws his kick and
you know gets a top five knockout of all
time which is very tough to land
and then he gets on the mic and he had a
plan didn't he had a plan he rips off
one hell of a promo one hell of a promo
so let's talk about what's next for
uncle chandler and this will
lead us into the main event
and i i'm gonna touch on the co-made
event because i definitely have opinions
on that
so for michael challen what's next for
him you know a lot of it's predicated
obviously he called out
um conor mcgregor and that's the money
fight
and again if you've watched a show over
the years you're not going to find a
bigger conor mcgregor fan than me i
absolutely love conor mcgregor for good
or bad i love conor mcgregor what he's
done for the sport the eyeballs that he
brings to sport obviously he's the
reason why i got the gig was show time
which led to this
amazing experience for damn near five
years with show time all that started
with this little
fight with floyd mayweather and conor
mcgregor i was the mma
expert
who would argue why conor could land a
punch
cool it led me down this road and i'm
forever grateful but even before that i
was a huge conor mcgregor fan some of
his antics outside that gun i know i get
it i get it but he's still the best to
ever do it financially not even close
ever so i root for that guy and and i i
do think he's a good person but i think
he's managing some demons and
his height of fame and the money it gets
it gets the lines get blurred for that
man okay
but here's the thing you know he he
broke his leg and i i think at the
earliest he come back in november
you know the year just started we're in
may so for chandler you're gonna wait to
november and from what i hear from my
sources
conor has no intention of fighting this
year
no intention this is why he's so big you
know so
if he did fight chandler would be at 70
but at the very very earliest you're
looking at november
i know michael chandler i know him
pretty well consider my friend he ain't
waiting in november that ain't happening
so you know with a knockout like that
you know he tosses his hat into the
the the title contention talk
you know charles oliveira currently
there is no lightweight champion in the
world because he missed weight
and i'll be honest at the show the early
show on saturday so many fans of the
mean greek go who do you got charles or
justin i said i did have charles but him
missing wait
i think i'm gonna go with gaichi i think
mentally that's a lot for charles to
take in he's probably getting a lot of
hate even though if he doesn't see it
i'm sure he can feel it
it has to take a mental toll on you to
miss weight you know you get stripped of
the title when you get stripped of the
title and no longer the champion well
then you don't get a pay-per-view
percentage so
there's so many things that you guys
don't think about or you do but there's
so many things i think a lot of people
don't think about how it affects charles
oliveira to miss wait financially
the the criticism
you know so i
you know this probably my own reflection
on the man is i went ah it's got a lot
to take on it's another mental hurdle he
has to over cheat you know achieve over
he's gonna get dicey for him just get
you the killer it's his hometown
i'll go with gaichi and i lost money on
justin gates
it was a fantastic fight back and forth
and charles oliveira showed you why he
might be the most entertaining man in
the sport
um you know he's notoriously known for
being a slow starter
not that night he dropped him dude and
he looked phenomenal his striking's
phenomenal his chin is unparalleled
and this notion and i've definitely gone
with this uh
kind of
notion that charles oliveira he had quit
in him you know when he was at 45 and
that never goes away
boy was i wrong that [ __ ] unreal
he is he's the best 155 around the
planet bar none and we all know he's the
champ you can take away his belt and you
know he missed weight and there's also a
conspiracy theory with that whatever he
did miss wait but we know he's the best
so for charles oliveira
what's his options well if you if you
look at it you know there's a lot of
talk of islam
which
i do think would give him his toughest
challenge even though he hasn't beat him
but really in the top 10 not his fault
you know he's supposed to fight dariush
and that fell out and they fought bobby
green
but for machev i do think he gives
charles oliveira the most problems
um
you know i don't know what the odds
would be on that the vegas odds so
remember though also makchev is
scheduled to fight daryush they were
supposed to fight previously before the
bobby green fight right so
i i would like to see him get a a win
over a top five guy before he fights for
a title
but i wouldn't be mad if he skipped
darius
darius fans don't come at me i i i'm
just saying i i could see the ufc doing
uh makachev and um charles oliveira mark
jeff opened as a betting favorite
heavy minus 415 in february though
hmm
i get it
i get it um i'm sick of doubting charles
oliveira i mean
what's the guy have to do before we
start giving his kudos well you looked
at on saturday night he had to do that
i'm all in um so for mokshev you know he
doesn't have a win over top 10 guy i
would like to see him fight uh darius
but if they want to skip that
all right if you want to do chandler
darius winner that's next in line
i take that
chandler uh daryush is a phenomenal
fight phenomenal fight but there's one
guy you guys are forgetting about
everybody in this room big george is in
here what's up big george
big george finally a thick boy man oh
yeah glad to have you brother
yeah love that you're here man
your energy is fantastic
i'm an energy guy man
yeah i hope you learned something being
here dude good to see you
um
george when i thought about this but
chin and casey you did not okay let's
see i think there's a chance this is a
big if
and they announced it i think saturday
night
alex volkowski who's on food truck and
he talked about how big he is and how he
goes against bigger guys and he has no
issues with it
he talks about he could easily fight at
55. i think
what's next for charles if i'm the ufc
that's what i do i think what's next for
charles oliveira this is a big gift so
this is
it's a bit of a stretch but hear me out
here
i think
alex wilkinowski
fights max holloway and i think they
announced that that that that what
trilogy fight yeah the trilogy fight
which i think alex needs to move on from
max holloway i think if alex were to get
by him at ufc 276 which hopefully do a
fight company for that
i think if alex wins that fight that's a
big gif you're talking about a huge max
hallway fan i [ __ ] love max hallway
but if alex volkanovsky
can beat max holloway which i think he's
probably slightly favored if he gets
past that fight
i think the next fight for him would be
charles oliveira at 55. i think that's
what's next for charles alovera i think
the ufc leaves
uh darius and makchev just so makachev
there's no
questions unanswered he has a top five
win and then you can say yes he is the
next title contender if i'm the ufc
that's what i do
it's a big if mm-hmm there's a lot that
has to happen
but you know
this narrative of conor mcgregor he's
perfect now i can jump in and and there
there's an interim title or there's no
legit uh light weight champion of the
world and this is perfect connor
fellas again you're talking about the
biggest conor dick rider in the world
and i'm telling you he ain't fighting
this year it ain't happening so we got
to move on i don't want to move on
nothing's i'm the business of views
nothing's better for views than conor
mcgregor i want him to fight seven times
a week but he doesn't
he ain't fighting this year
he's too big when he comes back to me at
70.
when you talk about all that you know
for conor i think what the ufc wants is
a nate diaz connor trilogy fight that's
to them the biggest fight they can make
they'll make the most money it's the
last five night diaz contract
but again i can't emphasize enough conor
ain't fighting this year nate diaz a
fighter's fighter is healthy he's ready
to go
he's ready
you think he's just gonna wait around
and get out of his contract until
connor's ready to go then you don't know
nate diaz he is not gonna do what connor
says or he's not gonna be on connor's
timeline he's nate diaz so what's next
for nate diaz
well there was this leak of dana doing
some podcasts and behind him
was the was it ufc 276 lineup revealed
shoulder you showed
hamzad versus nate diaz
i thought that's interesting
and i think they're considering it i
really do i think they're considering it
i think nate would be game and
the the great thing about uh the diaz
brothers is they'll fight anybody they
do not care and they are not scared of
hamza they're not
nadia's would take that find a heartbeat
but here's something i think you guys
are forgetting
chandler was saying that he's 36 he's
like you know 10 to 55 ain't healthy man
i'm 36 years old i'm down to fight at
70.
what about chandler diaz
you're open to chandler mcgregor
what if he beats nate
and then you give chandler mcgregor next
year when he's ready to go
so you're you're squeezing the juice out
of these two
superstars the the two biggest names of
the ufc you're getting double juice out
of them man
chandler's hot right now
hot that front kick he's hot
so i you know there's there's so much
that the ufc can do man there's so much
they can do the ufc you know they
announced that ufc 276 card with izzy
and cannon air and pedro munoz and sean
o'malley which i'm so excited for that
uh you know i
again there's not a bigger fan for for
izzy than me i i love izzy and how he
says aliens came down to earth and said
what's this ufc thing about i would show
them izzy's highlights i'm like this is
what it is he's the one guy would show
but i do think that cannonair poses a
lot of problems that you guys are
forgetting about as the fight gets
closer we'll break that down but i do
think canada has a style the forward
aggression
that again he's not as big as uh
jan blockovich that izzy lost at 205 but
he is a bigger dude and he does have a
wrestling background and he used to
fight at heavyweight and light
heavyweight he's a big strong guy
who has a lot of [ __ ] wins right
and you know
i don't think this can be as easy to
fight as you know the izzy fans think i
i do think he's going to pose some
problems
now does izzy figure out those problems
yes
but again i'm a huge izzy fan
but if you're a ufc fan these matchups
are boom booming daddy boomin i'm
excited for it super excited for it so
um again
i could i could see a chandler nate diaz
chandler's health i'm sorry chandler's
healthy nadia's healthy ideas ain't
gonna wait for conor to get a [ __ ]
together and want to fight
he has one fight left on his car he's
talked about going to bellator fighting
jake paul that's gonna happen i promise
you bellator i don't know talk about
jake paul that's gonna happen whether
the ufc ufc's involved with it or not
so for nate he's like dude just give me
a [ __ ] fight so i can move on
he's not gonna wait for connor you're
out of your mind it's not happening
michael chandler's healthy he's ready to
go
nadia's put out a tweet most people
thought it was for conor i think it was
for chandler
and i think chandler is looking at the
look at that july 30th 170.
we know for a fact
that
conor mcgregor ain't to be regular for
july 30th
so what's his options
there's hamzat
prasanza and you know obviously the ufc
is entertaining that there's that
i you know i just don't see i
i you know it's not an eight thing i
just don't see
hamza nate happening i think there's
something there i don't see it happening
i'm said [ __ ] you're not ashamed to
open your mouth at all you refuse to
fight ten times
interesting
i i really think it's it's nate diaz
chandler next
and channel's looking for a big fight
interesting right yeah
interesting volkanovsky charles oliveira
take my money that's a badass fight just
spitballing ideas
just spitballing that's all i'm doing
that's all dana said i don't know if
syrian couldn't mention we'll get to
that i saw dana say uh
fury rush francis is stupid blah blah
really
it wasn't stupid when conor fought floyd
mayweather when he made all the money
now that you don't have your hand in the
pie it's stupid
okay
it's stupid that france can make more
money than god
is he gonna win probably not i don't
give a [ __ ]
the guy's gonna make life-changing money
he never has to do anything ever again
his kids kids kids are rich if he's
smart with his money i want that for
them is he going to win probably not but
he has a better chance than conor
mcgregor beating floyd mayweather
because it's heavyweight anything can
happen and it's in four ounce gloves
how can you say it's stupid because
you're not involved
that's why it's not stupid
it's a great opportunity for francis
don't [ __ ] on it man
you know
all right what do you got jim
god it's good to be back
uh you covered a lot of the curves but
there's some more did i yeah that's
which is good
on the same page here's what's crazy i
don't even see him
that's just crazy that's cool
um
so there was a bunch of different
fighters hilarious if like all these
fights are like dude it's chandler
darius man
what and alex volkowski said he's never
fighting at 55
and they canceled the francis fight dude
you're way off that could be a
possibility who knows who knows and
welcome to the shop show
where i don't know what i'm talking
about
all right all right so the same card 276
no i'm sorry
276 yeah 276. um robbie lawler versus
brian barbarina that
is a fight
is that on the main card
maybe better be
that dude somebody going to sleep
that is a mother trucking fight son
cartoon
donkey
the matchmaking there
what
somebody been put in work
and what's uh that's brian saying what i
didn't listen to it got his beard it's
fantastic very duck dynasty
what's up bam bam nation and fight fans
today is my birthday but i want to leave
you with a gift
i'm finding robbie lawler july 2nd so be
sure to tune in it's going to be a barn
burner you don't want to miss it
damn
i'm what you say bam bam nation i think
so i'm bam bam nation
that's a great fight
my god
fantastic
and oh we did we didn't cover uh rose uh
esparza no he didn't let me cover that
real quick oh we didn't i'll be real
quick i know you guys are that fight
took 25 minutes of your life you're
never getting back so i'll touch on real
quick move on to the tournaments
rose and carla this is what happened
with that fight
rose is the best women's straw weight on
the planet when she's mentally prepared
and ready to go and wants to be in there
when rose has some sort of mental block
it's a tough night for her there's
nobody more talented on this planet than
rose
at the women's strawweight division
there's just not she's the best she's
the absolute best
i think this was
a case of rose have this mental block
where carla beat her if you remember
on the ultimate fighter finale correct
so in that ultimate fire finale when
carla beat her and she trained with her
she knows carlos sparza and shout out to
caller sparza for you know working her
way back and being a two-time world
champion phenomenal
people who are upset or throwing shade
at or you don't what are you talking
about
so
the losers of this fight are the fans
that paid it was awful it is but it
happens it's not their fault it happens
the reason why this fight was so boring
wasn't because of carlos because rose
rosie won't engage she has this mental
block
she had a mental block maybe she wanted
to do it that night they fight any other
night and rose is
in tune with herself and wants to be
there and gets out of her own way she
lights carl up
she lights her up but for the reason on
this particular saturday night at say 9
p.m pacific she didn't feel like doing
it and she had this
version of carl in her head where she
can't go forward and apply pressure
she's worried about getting taken down
even though she's fought monsters and
just gone droughts and all this stuff
where she never never ever had those
mental blocks but with carla she had a
mental block and made her something
she's not and was too scared to pull the
trigger and
you know she has one of the best corners
in the world and
trevor whitman and i are very close this
is not criticism this is just my opinion
for what it's worth
trevor you know i [ __ ] love you pat
bear you know i love you pepe was a
training part partner of mine we're
coaching the ultimate fighter i love the
entire team
that is surrounded by rose
my only criticism is is in the corner
saying you're up four rounds or you know
keep doing what you're doing i think
they did her disservice i don't think
they're being honest with her i think
that's why she lost the fight nobody won
this fight carla did just a hair more to
give it to the judges just to hear more
i guess
i guess nobody won
but i would bet my last dollar on rose
becoming champion
you got waylay versus yon jung check
coming up
rose beat both of them it's just a
matter of time rose can give her her
her title back i would bet my last
dollar on it
that's all i have to say about it you
guys have been tortured enough with that
fight i'll tell you right now i don't
see them fight ever again i know ever
again i don't give a [ __ ] carlos sparta
goes on to win 10 fights in a row and
rose wins 10.
like well it has to happen don't make it
happen do something else somebody cut
weight go down to [ __ ] whatever
i don't ever want to see it again never
paying for that again
but again this th this is all predicated
off rows having some weird mental block
and her corner not being honest with her
and they did her disservice
i wasn't cage site though i don't know
what they were seeing you know but that
wasn't the roads that we know and love
i'd love to hear argument for that i'm
telling you talent talent-wise they're
in a better straw weight on this [ __ ]
planet than rose there's also not a
better corner
there's not a better camp than rose's
camp trevor whitman pat berry and the
boys those are
super close friends this isn't criticism
i wasn't there
i was telling dick jokes in charlotte so
i had to watch it after
but from my outside perspective
my little experience in the ufc seven
years my little experience i thought
they could have been more honest with
her and uh
had her have more of a sense of urgency
that's what i would have done
i've never i have cornered in the ufc
i've never been in a championship
caliber fight in the ufc so i don't know
what they're dealing with i'm sure they
have their reasons
listen to them not me i'm just saying
the smelling criticism of the fight
but rose this hands down
the best women's strawberry on the
planet and this is a mental thing that's
it all right in and off night moving on
moving on
what do you got jim uh real quick on
that so
you mentioned the mental thing she
tweeted out later or just she made a
message about like she feels like a
shitty human being she's apologizing to
everyone and then a lot of fighters just
you know give her love and support after
that too so she might be going through
something right now yeah man yeah rose
is a sensitive flower you know mm-hmm
when she's tuned in
yeah she's amazing you got problems on
your hands kick in the face
so this happened
canelo alvarez actually lost it was a
unanimous decision against dimitri
people now if you look at the scorecard
so i watched this fight last night at
midnight because i'm a psycho
while my kids were sleeping my girl
sleeping i bought this
pay-per-view again because i'm a
psychopath i knew the results
because i i saw he lost him like damn
over what happened there was like a
weird thing and again i don't see
anything online so i was like let me
watch it for myself bro this fight
wasn't even close crazy yeah be valve
there you are i think it's beaver pavol
the ball beat his ass yeah beat his ass
now remember canelo's a guy who he's
taking chances he's fighting a super
middleweight and he's not big enough for
the weight class and you're gonna run
some of these guys man
you know and and jake paul or some guys
go you're fighting a guy with 3 000
twitter followers it's like
oh bubba
they don't care about tick tock and
youtube and you know to me uh
dim tree b-ball dim tree
he's not doing tick-tock dances he's not
doing click-bait [ __ ] or drama podcast
drama or none of that stuff
he's fighting
he's gonna have a big fallen that
[ __ ] can
you cannot learn the hard way you know
so
um you're like in the the
the triple g
uh trilogy fight out of this he he's
gonna use his
you know mandated uh rematch clause and
you're going to get that again
i'm sure you get a different uh canelo
but even a different canelo it's just
it's tough man evolve i i know you guys
don't know who he is he's a [ __ ]
monster you know and cadella i think for
him
he knew this was a tough fight maybe he
didn't you know get up for it or
whatever but he knows what he's doing
even though this isn't the most famous
guy maybe you've never heard of him
but canelo is trying to do make history
and fight the best boxers not the most
famous and that's what happened here you
know
all right uh going back to the
fight this past weekend so obviously
cowboy cerrone couldn't fight you got
sick the next day yeah food poisoning
that's oily yeah so he cut weight right
and then uh felt great and then uh
rehydrated and ate food and whatever
food he ate he got food poisoning yeah
that's what i heard yeah
but he loved don cerrone yeah he's
always entertaining but he revealed that
he only wants to fight until 50 fights
so that would have been his 49th so he's
saying he's gonna retire after two more
fights that's cool he deserves it man
one of the greats
uh cerrone uh you know he's a colorado
kid so me and cerrone cerney was doing a
lot sore was in wc at the time he came
up in the tap out show if you remember
the tap out show on altitude tv i think
i forgot what channel yeah but he came
up on that tap out show but in denver he
was already a big deal big deal and when
i started you know if you got an mma you
knew donald cerrone and he started with
dwayne ludwig in denver and then moved
out to uh new mexico with greg jackson
when i was just starting i was a nobody
man nobody
this is what kind of guy donald cerrone
is that's what you're dealing with
donald cerrone i was a nobody and i was
with my friend cody dahman who's also a
nobody and cody kind of knew donald and
donald because we went we wanted to go
down to jackson's because we were
fighting the ring of fire which was a
local denver show and we were in camp
for it and donald didn't really know us
and his roommate was leonard garcia the
great leonard garcia who i absolutely
love the nicest guy in the business
um
donald let us stay at his house he fed
us remember at the time i have no money
he fed us gave us per diems
uh would would drive us to training camp
at jackson's it's like you can stay as
long as you want rent free man cool yeah
the best the best man
that goes such a far away he's such a
good person such a good person man
that's cool great guy
what else you got all right um let's
start with
yeah this one
let me said that there might be a
conspiracy with the skills
so dana white even said that
he thinks people are tinkering with it
because it's an adjustment from pounds
to kilos and there's european
international fighters that are changing
it to kilos americans change it to
pounds he thinks something might happen
there because other fighters can
complain about the different you know
before charlotte yeah interesting so
he's gonna he said now he's gonna have
probably a security guard or security
team check the skills be there when they
do that stuff now god i wish i could do
that
that's how you get back in with dana
white i'm the i'm the security scale guy
yeah
i have nothing to do i'm just chilling
by the scale so guarding it
that'd be sick that'd be dope it'd be a
dope job yeah but i only want to do it
for big pay-per-views yeah it'd be
boring fight nights and [ __ ] or if
you're in abu dhabi i won't travel to
abu dhabi but if it's like a huge like
vegas or phoenix or houston or
jacksonville new york your boy's there
i'm just guarding the things taking
pictures
i'd be sick you know
it'd be a great job i wonder who they're
going to give it to
i mean
they gotta actually hire some retired
fire and pay him up the [ __ ] gazoo
yeah
yeah your heart breaks for charles
oliveira but i did see that people were
saying like dude the scale was off which
is
when you're talking about ounces and you
know
half a pound
and it dictates charles oliveira's
purse and pay-per-view points and you
know income and it affects his family
and training camp oh my god
the [ __ ] rolls down he'll you gotta have
somebody on it got it you just have to
and he lost i think thirty thousand
dollars on that compliance pay with that
whatever that pay is to do all the stuff
you do just because of that too oh dude
he gets away from that because the in
the in the contract you miss wait you're
no longer the champ yeah there's no
pay-per-view points you're talking about
millions of millions of dollars millions
of dollars damn
totally heartbreaking yeah heartbreaking
then if you're not champ you're just
another guy when you champ you make some
real money especially your multiple
defending world champion you're making
real money
didn't make real money though half pound
oh that's crazy let's play [ __ ] with the
scale
and the guy still
put on damn show you what
mind blowing
after watching that fight everyone was
just like he's just [ __ ] oh i was
like yeah i'm in yep
i'm on the bronx train no more equating
no there's no quit that guy who the [ __ ]
said that no it's completely different
that's 155 on the planet yep i'm in
incredible
what else you got your boy luke rockhold
he's coming back and he's fighting
holocaust i love this like god the
build-up to this the trash talk
sign me up yeah
luke i know you watch the show
i can't emphasize enough if you don't
use your world class grappling
i'm gonna do nothing i'm gonna i'm after
your fight i'm coming on the show and
just talk about it but still
dude
you talk he rolls with the very best in
the world i'm not going to mention names
you know him in the jutsu community
anybody i talk to i've seen it firsthand
at ak he goes down to florida
i'm telling you man
the biggest names in the game in jiu
jitsu luke will
roll out of bed hung over from partying
and doing whatever a model does
and beats the [ __ ] out of him
his grappling is
nutsos but he left stand-up
you know yeah
if you don't use your
world-class grappling against paulo
costa i'm gonna freak out and do nothing
about it
just it's a great fight though yeah
good comeback fight for him um
curtis blades versus tom aspinall you'll
see london that's like he's getting up
there right now
to the top dogs i don't like this
i mean
i'm not
i tread lightly here because curtis
blades trains my team i love curtis
blades and i there's nowhere else for
him to go so it makes sense and i always
root for curtis i do think he can be
champion he has all the assets to be
champion
he's
silenced the haters with his exciting
fights as of late
you guys know i always root for the the
english guys right being half english my
mom was born and raised in england so i
just have a connection with the english
fighters so i root for tom aspinall if
you remember after his big win
uh over uh
volkov
i said though
let's see what the ufc wants to do
let's see how much they want tom to be
champion you're going to tell by his
next fight if they give him curtis
blades
which is a the worst matchup possible in
the top five
they're not that high on them if they
give them
tai to avasa
then then they want him to be champion
because
any of these top five guys could be a
world champion especially with francis
gone and focus on uh fury any one of
them can be champion it just just
matters who the ufc wants to be champion
there's easier roads to get there
they have given tom aspinall the
toughest road possible this is a
nightmare of a match up for him can he
win 100 percent he could still win
it's the worst matchup possible for him
now this level
going back to ed soares she told me this
a long time ago who's the manager for
machida and nancy and sylvan big nog and
little nog and any name a brazilian
fighter he's a manager he goes
if when they call me i say yes every
time because any fire that i represent
can beat anybody at any given day and if
you can't you shouldn't be in the ufc he
goes just like the nfl
if the nfl calls and goes hey week three
you have the la rams you know oh they're
really good i can't we can't beat them
give us somebody else you have done work
like that
ufc is the top
upper echelon of sports so anytime they
call me we say yes it's what we do i'm
like that makes sense i apologize for
being opposed
but so tom [ __ ] is going to take this
fight i'm just saying out of taitu avaso
had been so much fun
you know derek lewis he was coming up
there's so many ways they could have
went about it but they gave him a
monster you know but it's in london so
he's gonna have that local you know home
crowd and uh
it's the again i'm not saying he can't
win but it is the most difficult
journey to the title possible for tom
aspinall but i'm still rooting for him
yeah it's a little surprising
uh on that same card darren till's
coming back oh [ __ ] jack cremanson i
didn't know that mm-hmm that's a good
fight yeah it's a great fight
do you until obviously trading with
hamzad hopefully he has his you know his
wits about him and wants to be in there
and has gotten better and you know i
root for for darren till i really do
and your boy
taito ivasa they got him a fight
oh [ __ ]
what an interesting way to go for the
ufc i know i would have done opposite
i would have done i would have done it
backwards i would have done the opposite
of this
the last two yeah
yeah i would have done ty versus aspinal
whenever that gets the title shot
because
either way you're getting a personality
in the title fight
um you know cyril gone and curtis blaze
don't have the biggest personalities
i would do
non-personalities first personalities
and then go you know for the interim
heavyweight title that's what i would
done i think they made the wrong call
here um i think it's you know again for
taito vasa this is the toughest fight
possible it's the worst matchup can he
win of course
but level of difficulty for tai chuavasa
and astimanol is way higher now because
tai chuavasa and astanal is a phenomenal
fight
dude peanut butter and jelly baby
peas and carrots
this forest gum jenny said jenna
old school reference but either way
i they just were whoever was in that war
room in the ufc was like
here's what we're gonna do
i don't agree with it i wouldn't have
done it
because tattoo vasa aspinal in london is
fireworks fireworks
serogon versus curtis blades
that's a
strategic upper echelon fight
i would have done it yeah you wouldn't
have done it
dude yeah we finally got the shoei tai
chi of love you
love you you know this i love you i know
that took
12 weeks to come in dude it was forever
six months six months roughly
i don't know your customer service is
but
it took
six months to come in ty
to l.a
all the boys you guys posted too did you
tag them
dope
it looked small though i was expecting a
bigger shoe
[Music]
hey this isn't a frat house this is a
studio a white call did you rush
afterwards
god damn it guys
cows are frat now
all right what else you got jen uh this
one alexander gustafson versus
yeah
because he was supposed to fight ben
rothwell but now yeah
ben roth was in bks
fox finding ben roth with bare knuckles
people are savages
this is a crazy one
that's a main event too
this gets my day card cater versus josh
emmett fantastic main event that's a
fight night in austin daddy
that's a great freaking fight definitely
a great fight
and then we have kevin holland tim means
espn37
oh dude hats off kudos cheers the
matchmakers kevin hong tim beans jesus
christ
that's an awesome too yeah
god damn
fantastic and this is a surprising one
cody garbrandt and
hani aya interesting
yaya is
57 years old he is the brian cowan of
the ufc he's been he's been doing it
forever
yeah great so with cody you know coming
off those losses yeah these two
well-known guys find each other i would
assume losers fight gets cut uh they're
both fighting for their jobs
and i can't emphasize enough
how bad i want cody garbrandt to win how
good is i hate to pick favorites sorry
yanni never met you don't know you
cody's my guy yeah need him to win i
mean we know he's an amazing striker but
how good is this ground game
his wrestling's [ __ ] spot-on you know
but yeah ronnie is world-class on the
ground yeah
um
this woman was also very surprising so
that be magametripov
or some [ __ ] he's working in the medical
industry
doctors of the world
here's arms of all time here's my thing
here's forums you've ever seen harris
everything dude it just here for day
everywhere yes
um
good for him yeah
you know
he's a phenomenal talent i'd love to see
him you know be the the world champion
the efc but if you want to pursue
a career in the medical field
good for you man yeah if you're smart
enough you have the wits to pursue that
career
and you decide that you're more
interested in that than mma good for you
men
good for you
to get out of that shell that a lot of
people just say oh you're just a ufc
fighter you're just a fighter nah man
i'm gonna do this
good for you
no one should hate on that that should
inspire everybody the guy goes from mma
being that hairy
into the medical field in that area and
to have the iq and the wits to pull that
off god bless you man and he was killing
it too he's like leaving on top five
yeah monster he has all the potential to
be world champion i was like nah i'm
good i'm gonna do this and he's only 31.
yeah it's good for him man i celebrate
that yeah that is not a sad story that
is a success story
all right let's do
a couple more this is uh jake paul he
posted on his i think his twitter
yeah his twitter just says back august
13th
and then i guess there's
rumors that it's going to be tommy fear
for sure ooh i like that
now is he going to sell all the
pay-per-views i don't know i don't know
tommy fury you're tom fury is coming off
the win he's on the undercard of his
brother's fight
um you know for jake he's on a different
path than his brother and i think you
know he wants to
you could i don't think anybody's going
to say tommy fury's not a boxer right
because he's fighting boxing and he's
fighting professional boxing and his
brothers tyson fury the best ever do it
so
i think for jake this checks a couple
boxes i think it's more personal and i
think he knocks tommy fury yeah i do
which is crazy
and then the train continues
all right we just had patty pimlin on
and he shared if you haven't seen it
patty is uh on the latest food truck
diaries one of my favorite he's such a
good person man the fifth beatle we shot
in uh san diego california the laugh
factory one of our favorite food trucks
too but patty's great yeah he's so
entertaining you get why he's such a big
start right away you're like that makes
sense
savage yeah
so he was sharing a story about stefan
bonner i guess when he was around 12
years old he wanted to take a picture of
uh with stephan bonner i guess they're
doing some sort of thing in europe okay
and then
he's just like i don't have time he just
walked by and he never forgot that
that's why he always takes pictures with
people right now but he's still like
he's still upset about it yeah hell yeah
that stuff never leaves you
never leave you i had a guy yeah i
remember i was selling supplements at
the time and uh
vanderlei silva was doing an autographed
sighting and i was such a big fan from
his pride days he just came to ufc to do
an autograph sign at like this
bodybuilding.com expo or some [ __ ] like
that i wait in line for an hour to get
his autograph and he signed the eight by
tens of the ufc uh yo what's up man he
goes oh what's up what's your name i go
uh brendan it was brandon no no it's
brendan yes yeah and then signs brandon
i was like god damn it at least you
signed it though yeah let's decide it
yeah well how's the kid i got snubbed by
uh mlb player i don't know it just hurt
your feelings did he even acknowledge
you or just no no my dad was like hey my
son we he he caught the foul ball he
signed and the guy's like not tonight
not tonight sucks bro you play for the
cincinnati reds
if it's not tonight it's never happening
sir i'm
i'm eight
i'm not going to cincinnati you [ __ ]
me dude no no now i don't like you
anymore you know yeah it just takes that
one thing yep
um this is the last one for current
events this is just
okay just pay attention to uh jared
cannon here this is at the usc there's
al jamaine sterling
he is not with it
he's just like
it's that's his personality too right
yeah he's just a savage all right about
his winning he's just such a savage deer
cannon here's not having it no and
i don't think it's that he's not having
fun he's just like i ain't doing this
tick tock [ __ ] hypey [ __ ] man yeah
you know he's focused and he should be
good for him man yeah is that it that's
it for kermit man it's good to be back
in the home home home town
home field advantage here
uh you have a fight night this saturday
night at 7 00 p.m pacific
you have young blokovich versus racquet
and it's a great main event that that
co-main event ain't too shabby either
with ryan spann and cuda liba
uh chuda ken amanda ribes is fun you
know it's not gonna blow your hair back
you have michael johnson on there i'm
definitely gonna watch it though tell
you that right now that's my saturday
night and thank you ufc oh thank you
oh thank you
so yeah that's it man well i got one
more what uh michael michael page and
logan storley oh yeah yeah machida
fabian edwards paul
shout out to paul daley
that's fun man yeah that's on a friday
that's friday bellator 1 p.m
show time yep nice
definitely watch that as well uh thank
you yeah that's something pretty much
thank you
uh for your boy here the trash panda
tour
is next week philadelphia one of my
favorite cities philly
what's up holla at your boy i will be in
this hat strolling your freaking streets
in philadelphia pennsylvania
i'm at the helium next thursday friday
saturday in philadelphia and then los
angeles the shob and friend show
continues with some
monsters one show only wednesday may
25th at 8pm
and then portland a little fact about
portland they have the most strip clubs
per capita in the united states
now they are pasty white girls with
tattoos
to each their own i don't go to them
but
just a little fact for you
big george you're probably going to be
there
fantastic if you want to come for reals
i'll make it happen but that is june 9th
through the 11th in portland that's also
the helium portland one of my favorite
freaking clubs i've done in a jagillion
times portland is june 9th through 11th
san francisco at cobbs robin williams
old club man june 17th through 18th last
time i cried when i was there and then
san diego california is the uh laugh
factory san diego new club out there
july 21st and july through the july 23rd
looking forward to that but philly
europe baby trash panda tour the thick
boys are coming through
your city that's next thursday through
saturday may 19th through 21st trash
panda tour continues on all right
tickets at thickboy.com or
f-a-t-k-z.com osco also osco costco osco
um
uh the tiger thick whiskey is finally
available we have an online distributor
thank god uh we're in stores nationwide
i think we're in 45 cities we have five
more to go we're in 45 cities so if you
can't get at your local liquor store go
to thickboy.com get it online ships to
your crib what's up
tigerthink is available right now at
thickboy.com
if you want to see my special the green
girl poppy is available on thick boy
youtube and i am so goddamn proud of it
thank you guys for watching thanks for
subscribing liking thank you for the
support i love you guys philly i will
see you next week that's it be nice to
each other i'm out